[Music]
moving on our main story tonight
concerns pollution it's the thing that
psas have been warning us about for more
than half a century now
before you take another breath think
what air pollution may be doing to your
lungs
hold it now
think what are you going to do about it
well if there are groups in your town
fighting to make the air clean join them
or write to clean air washington dc uh
by the way
holding your breath is not the answer
flawless not a single floor the only
thing i'd say there is you could have
had a little more fun with what's
written on the balls that's it
you're already the flirtiest weirdo
1960s psa has had to offer swing big you
could have gone with bet you didn't know
these were in my mouth or these are
kermit's eyes or robert kennedy will be
shot on june 5th 1968. the world was
your oyster there
look we all suffer from exposure to
pollution in this country but some
significantly more than others thanks to
what's called environmental racism
studies have found that black americans
are exposed to 38 more polluted air and
are 75 more likely to live in
communities that border a plant or a
factory and crucially the disparity in
exposure persists even when controlling
for income one study found that on
average black americans making two
hundred thousand dollars were exposed to
more air pollution than white americans
making twenty five thousand proving yet
again
racism is one of the few things in this
country more powerful than money in fact
i believe america's current top five
power rankings go racism beef viral
videos of soldiers reunited with their
dogs dj khaled's pr team and then money
and while the decisions that lead to
disparate outcomes can be subtle they
can also be incredibly flagrant in 2008
there was a massive spill of coal ash
here in tennessee with tons of toxic
waste dumped into a largely white
community now the good news is they
removed 4 million tons of it the bad
news is it was then dumped 300 miles
away in this largely black community
called uniontown where residents were
pretty clear about what had just
happened
taking that from a white area the white
people didn't want it let's just keep it
100. if white folks ain't wanted why do
you think it's good enough for the
blacks yeah she's absolutely right it
seems when white people don't want
something anymore they either dump it on
minority communities or sow a
hummingbird on it and listed on etsy as
handmade vintage let's keep it 100 for a
second that is garbage
the fact is though black neighborhoods
in particular can get targeted with
incredible precision and the stakes
could not be higher here pollution is
one of the driving factors behind
conditions like heart disease asthma and
even death with black americans nearly
three times as likely to die from
exposure to pollution and vast
disparities can even exist within the
same city as this environmental expert
breaks down
right now the zip code is the most
important predictor of health and
well-being you tell me your zip code i
can tell you how healthy you are all zip
codes are not created equal really yes
you can find zip codes that are adjacent
to each other and have a life expectancy
disparity of 10 15 years depending on
what's in that neighborhood and what's
not in that neighborhood
wow that is grim you can live 15 fewer
years depending on your zip code is the
worst zip code news since the time that
they added those four [ __ ] digits at
the end i don't know what those are and
i am never going to learn them i know my
five digit zip code my social security
number my birthday one of my children's
birthdays and that is the end of my
numbers i'm not learning anymore
so given just how awful its effects are
tonight let's take a look at
environmental racism how it got this bad
how government and industry continue to
fail people of color and what we can do
about it and the first major factor to
consider here is history as we've
discussed before on this comedy show it
was explicit federal policy for decades
to segregate housing based on race
through a process known as redlining
basically black people could not get
government-backed home loans where white
people lived and the areas where they
could live were often also zoned for
industrial uses here's how it worked in
dallas
so you can take a redlining map from the
30s and maps from the 40s and overlaid
that on a current industrial map of
dallas and they'll show you black and
brown folks are forced to live side by
side by heavy industry in a way that
nobody else in dallas was forced to live
that's basically the same parts of town
which does seem pretty intentional i
know some things are just weird
coincidences like how john adams and
thomas jefferson died on the same day or
how george washington had wooden teeth
and patrick henry died of anal splinters
just a random true fact that they don't
teach you about in history class but
this
this is no coincidence and that might at
least partly explain why the life
expectancy here in jopli a predominantly
black area with a lot of industrial
zoning is just 71 while in the
predominantly white highlands park it is
84. and it definitely helps explain why
certain neighbors have to put up with
[ __ ] like shingle mountain that is the
work of a company named blue star
recycling which claimed it had a plan to
recycle roofing shingles into asphalt so
it started dumping a literal mountain of
them into a lot right next to homes in a
largely black and latino neighborhood
look at it shingle mountain wow
that's a hundred thousand tons of
shingles
a hundred thousand tons of shingles
exactly wow
it kind of smells like
like just rubber like raw rubber it does
it smells like burnt payment not a
violation excuse me
bless you
yeah i think i feel like you're driving
back here
yeah it is this one yeah you can feel it
going up your nose mm-hmm yeah you get
your ex you feel it on the mouth excuse
me bless you okay look sneezing in
response to 100 000 tons of fiberglass
waste is fine a couple of times but
there is a point when you're just
interrupting people and it is rude
still still you cannot deny it is
impressive that it took all of five
seconds for that mountain to turn solid
at o'brien into a woman at the beginning
of an allergy commercial when she's
still in black and white
and blue star's owner chris ganta did
not seem that concerned about the mess
that he made because watch what happened
when o'brien managed to stop sneezing
for long enough to call him
so let me ask you a question when you
think of the people who live there on
shingle mountain like what would you say
to them because you know
it's pretty gross the whole neighborhood
around there's gross i mean uh
everything around there is uh an
industrial area i didn't really go down
there very often because i didn't like
being down in that part of part town but
do you think the people there you know
do you feel sorry for them do you feel
like hey listen that's where they live
they get what they get i mean everybody
knew what the zoning of the area was
when they when they bought i mean it's
kind of like
i don't know buying right next to the
nuclear place and then complaining later
about it that's an industrial area and
every city has to have an industrial era
just the way it is
you know part of me almost appreciates
that level of unapologetic shittiness no
efforts to spin or dodge it just flat
out saying yeah it's an icky part of
town full of gross poors who deserve to
live in filth did you get all of that
for your news report i can say it again
slower if it helps
but what ganter clearly does not
understand there is that a lot of people
didn't choose to live in an industrial
area racist zoning policies chose for
them and while his company eventually
went belly up and local activists got
the city to move the shingles it only
moved them just across the highway to a
massive landfill allowed by the
neighborhood zoning but history and
zoning are only part of the story here
because it also is about who has the
power to push back and polluters often
assume that black communities in
particular won't be able to stop them
take the by halia pipeline it was a
joint venture between these two
companies who planned for their oil
pipeline to take a very deliberate path
through memphis
the path by halia proposed winds down
through south memphis cutting through
several historically black communities
there is a more direct option but that
would cut through predominantly white
wealthier neighborhoods in the north
yeah that does seem a little odd doesn't
it normally the shortest distance
between two points is a straight line
not through any black people who happen
to be living nearby although i will say
the least surprising thing there is that
the white wealthy suburb is called
germantown
that is the name you give your community
when aryanville feels a little too
obvious
and while the companies behind the
bahalia pipeline insist that they had
good reasons for choosing the path that
they did according to a local activist a
rep for them once accidentally said the
quiet part out loud there was a
community meeting
that by halia pipeline held
and they were asked by one of the
members of the community why did you all
choose this route
and there's usually a pr answer but
instead the representative was pretty
clear and plain
what do you say we basically chose a
point of least resistance
when people aren't scripted you can
really learn what they believe and what
they think wow
you don't usually get a corporate pr
line quite so honest there is a reason
that apple slogan is think different and
not we made all the ports different
again what are you gonna do nothing
you'll do nothing you'll buy a hundred
dollars of new cars that'll last you
until next year when we vent some [ __ ]
called usbq or whatever it's not even
about the money for us anymore it's
about the erotic rush of power
now
i have to tell you the pipeline company
insists that that rep's answer did not
reflect the company's views and that he
should have said that they look for
roots with the least collective impact
to the community and that definitely
does sound better than the actual truth
which is that largely minority
communities often are seen as the path
of least resistance while local
activists have tried to resist and for
decades they've often done it alone as
big environmental groups historically
haven't been the best allies as this
climate justice activist points out the
priorities of the environmental movement
have tended to leave certain communities
out we need to redefine environmentalism
to to think more inclusively than the
traditional perception of the
environmental movement which tends to be
on you know saving the whales or flora
and fauna i did a talk recently in a
national park and when it was being
advertised there were people who were
perplexed and people who were actually
opposed
to having a conversation about
environmental justice she's right
environmentalism clearly shouldn't just
be about protecting wild spaces humans
do need protection too and i know it's
not the most popular start but maybe
conservationists could redirect some of
the resources to environmental justice
that they've been completely wasting on
pandas and i mean specifically pandas we
spent so much time saving them and why
exactly they don't want to be here they
don't [ __ ] each other they spend most of
their time falling off something
seriously you watch videos of pandas
they're constantly falling down it's
time to let them go as fast as they let
go to whatever they are holding
and the thing is at least with something
like shingle mountain you can see it so
you know to fight it but sometimes
pollution can be invisible and those
that you'd expect to warn you about that
can be incredibly slow to do so when it
comes to communities of color you're
probably already familiar with what
happened to the residents of flint
michigan but that is the tip of the
iceberg here take the west calumet
housing complex in east chicago indiana
a federally assisted housing community
built on top of a former lead smelter
the lead levels there were dangerously
off the charts how far off the charts
i'll let this reporter fill you in well
the safe level is supposed to be 400
parts per million well they found levels
of 1200 parts per million which is
already an emergency level but in some
areas in the soil underneath the ground
they have found areas of 45 000 parts
per million and even 90 000 parts per
million it's true they found lead more
than 200 times higher than the level
requiring cleanup which just isn't great
when the place that you found it is the
ground a thing notoriously difficult to
avoid unless that is you willing to
spend the rest of your life playing a
very high stakes version of the floor is
lava
but what's even worse is the government
knew the area was dangerously toxic
decades before they told anyone who
lived there time and again regulators
had the opportunity to tell residents
and they just didn't like in 1985 when
the epa first found high levels of lead
in the soil near the housing complex
they didn't notify residents or later in
1998 when the department of health and
human services and state health
officials found 30 of children under 6
in the housing complex had elevated
blood lead levels they didn't notify
residents flash forward to 2009 the epa
declared the land west calumet was on a
superfund site marking it a priority for
contamination cleanup and still didn't
notify residents a quick side note here
they didn't have to do that because fun
fact federal law doesn't require its
agencies to tell tenants that a unit is
located on a superfund site which i
truly cannot wrap my head around the
whole point of superfund is to
officially classify something in the
government record as very dangerous so
it is not great to do that and then not
tell the people actually at risk it's
like putting a do not leave lean over
the fence sign at a bear exhibit and
having it face the bear site sure the
information's technically out there but
it's not really doing much to improve
public safety
anyway in 2014 the epa the doj the state
of indiana and the corporations
responsible for the contamination agreed
on a remediation plan but still didn't
tell residents about the danger in fact
it was only in 2016 when the epa found
those lead levels in the soil hundreds
of times their maximum permitted level
that the city finally sent a letter to
residents telling them about the
contamination that is 31 years and eight
government agencies later and even then
the steps the government took were
utterly pathetic
on monday the epa will be passing out
flyers like these which have lots of
safety tips including reminding families
not to let their children play in the
dirt play on the grass and to remove
their shoes before walking into their
homes i've been told to
just keep your children out of the grass
and
out of the areas for the mulches
how do you do that when children play
that's what they do
she's right kids want to run around and
play although in the government's
defense they did put up that sign and we
all know there is nothing children
respect more than the authority of a
flimsy sign sorry friends no frolicking
hijinks or tomfoolery for us today after
all the sign is watching us
and while the details in this example
may be extraordinary it is worth noting
that 70 percent of hazardous waste sites
on the superfund list are located within
one mile of federally assisted housing
but look this isn't just about cleaning
pollution that's already happened it's
about deciding where industries will be
allowed to pollute going forward and
without significant changes our whole
system is currently set up so that
places that have already been polluted
get worse and worse there's even a term
for this sacrifice zones areas of the
country where it is both government
policy and industry practice to
concentrate polluters basically the
thinking is if you are zoned for
industry and a company is already there
what's one more
but people live in those zones and one
such area in louisiana has even come to
be known by an incredibly bleak name
more than 100 petrochemical plants and
refineries dot this corridor between new
orleans and baton rouge often referred
to as cancer alley reserve is right in
the middle of it the epa says the cancer
risk here is almost 50 times the
national average they built this
monstrosity up on top of us even the
town cemetery is surrounded by a
refinery okay
first putting an oil refinery around a
cemetery is pretty on the nose but also
let's not gloss over the term cancer
alley it is pretty upsetting to learn
that that's a name for an actual place
where people live and not what you'd
assume a slang term for the marble man's
ass crack
it's no wonder frankly that residents of
cancer alley are so angry that
industries have been allowed to move in
right next to them and yet infuriatingly
some local government officials try to
downplay the risks i think cancer alley
the term cancer alley is a myth
really that needs to be debunked
data that we received from the tumor
registry reports that it's not cancer
alley
oh okay then
uh but a few things on that first a
tumor registry may be one of the saddest
things that i've ever brought up on this
show and we've talked about everything
from baby crib grenades to orthodontic
bullying to the elderly being eaten by
alligators one of those things is real
by the way and you'll never guess which
one mainly because two of those are real
but second you should know that since
that clip researchers have in fact found
that toxic air pollution is linked to
higher cancer rates among impoverished
communities in louisiana including this
guy's [ __ ] parish and while local
politicians and industry will be quick
to point out the potential economic and
employment benefits that come with
industry as a local activist points out
that is something of a devil's bargain
if uh
isis showed up
and they said they would create jobs
would we let them in exactly and for the
record that man is a retired three-star
general so when he is comparing
something to isis he is really comparing
something to isis
and as residents there will point out
they are right now in many ways trapped
why haven't you moved
why should i move how can i move
i
i struggle all my life to build this
right now in good conscience who would i
actually sell this house to
what poor unsuspecting family
would i trick into moving into this debt
trap look i know the reporter is just
doing her job there but that is such a
ridiculous question that that man would
have been fully within his right to make
the rest of that interview the most
passive aggressive interaction of all
time why don't i move ha now you mention
it i hadn't even considered moving away
from cancer alley it just sounded so
nice to me what a great idea you just
had hold on let me throw up a zillow
listing for death trap and i'll just sit
back and wait for a bidding war to begin
and when you put all of this together a
history of racist zoning ineffective
regulation and the government that
continues to prioritize the profits of
industry over the health of people it is
clear we have a massive problem and the
good news is the current president
actually seems to agree with that
the unrelenting impact of climate change
affects every single solitary one of us
but too often lebron falls
disproportionately on communities of
color
exacerbating the need for anxiety for
environmental justice sorry as a bug
speaking of the environment
look
i don't love that a random bug
undermines the genuinely important point
that he was making there but i will say
this at least now biden knows what it
feels like when someone creeps out on
the back of his neck
but the fact is the fact is though biden
did make environmental justice a pillar
of his campaign and since taking office
he's promised among other things to
funnel 40
of relevant climate investments to
disadvantaged communities and to issue a
yearly scorecard that measures progress
which sounds great
unfortunately so far his administration
still hasn't set clear goals to
accomplish this and even worse in
february it said race will not be a
factor in deciding where to focus
efforts which is pretty [ __ ]
infuriating and the administration will
point out that the supreme court in its
current makeup is likely to strike down
any explicitly race-based policy which
may well be true but we're in a pretty
[ __ ] backwards situation when any
solutions to this problem have to be
race blind despite the fact that the
causes of it are so demonstrably not
so what can we do here what as you've
seen again and again in the stories
tonight it is local activists on the
ground who've been working tirelessly to
fight for their communities and to gain
concessions and they deserve much more
support from larger environmentalist
groups even as they continue leading the
way as for the government level we need
significant zoning reform to keep
polluters and residents safely apart
because the status quo is just not
acceptable because when this country
designates communities of color as
sacrifice zones the clear message there
is that the people who live in them are
expendable that it's okay for their kids
to not be able to play outside and for
their life spans to be shorter and
unless we make big steps to address
environmental racism and call it what it
is a brutal divide is going to stay in
place in this country where some are
treated like they're worth protecting
and others like they can be sacrificed
you